[Music]
kids can crack us up in many different
ways but often they're much more
innocent than they are inappropriate
these kids unknowingly left answers for
their teachers that certainly have them
crunched over in hysterics number one
we'll have you in stitches are you new
around here
if so welcome to the things give us a
like and hit the subscribe button to be
the first up-to-date now let's check out
twenty most inappropriate but innocent
kid test answers mrs. Edwards bad habit
throughout school the number of tests
and quizzes are just too much to keep
track but do you all remember elementary
school when the teachers were so cool we
all wanted to hang out with them sure
that changes in high school but younger
children love being pals with their
teachers in this kids class apparently
mrs. Edwards got a little too close to
her student one student answered on his
test I like when she does meth with us
we're pretty sure this teach isn't
smoking anything suspicious with her
class math is just way too close to meth
in spelling go get him mrs. Edwards gaga
forever okay so we have a couple
questions about this test answer first
why are these young children having a
test on hermaphrodites and second who
told this child Lady gaga was a
hermaphrodite now we all know gaga is a
woman but we couldn't help but find this
answer hilarious with all her crazy
costumes and huge personality maybe this
little one got hermaphrodite confused
with someone outgoing or perhaps this
was the classic case of a kid repeating
what they heard at home either way we're
loving it all or nothing this kid has
some big dreams but let's be real
anything is possible
right well mostly anything it's
beautiful how kids can look up to their
idols and Chris clearly looked up to his
basketball hero Michael
when asked how he would accomplish this
goal he answered get bigger shave my
head and be black way to go buddy we
wonder how it's all been coming along
for him the most lovely part of this is
kids don't see anything stopping them
not even the color of their skin and
that is awesome
but ain't nobody Michael Jordan except
Michael Jordan the situation we all
remember the days of the hit reality
series Jersey Shore with a fabulously
outlandish characters and even crazier
arguments Jersey Shore was an MTV show
that followed around 20-something adults
and their lives in the Jersey Shore it
became wildly successful and even
reached elementary schools some of the
lead characters had crazy nicknames like
Pauly D and sweetheart
but the best known name was the
situation apparently even the youngest
in grade school heard about this when
asked to draw a picture of the situation
this kid drew Mike Sorrentino better
known as the situation from the Jersey
Shore you can't help but laugh at this
one chase your dreams we all have dreams
about the future when we were young
parents and teachers encouraged us to do
whatever we love and chase our dreams
one kid in particular has some big
dreams and certainly seems to have his
priorities straight when asked what
three things he wanted to do in the
future
he answered get a girlfriend kiss her
and rule the world well that seems
pretty legit to us three points for
three great answers from this kid we
want to know what he's doing now does he
have a girlfriend
did he kiss her and most importantly is
he ruling the world Penn is goat school
faced us with all sorts of tests and
didn't always set us up for success just
like this test a kid made a hilarious
mistake filling out one of his answers
the question had scrambled up words and
the kids needed to reword them into a
sentence however when ten and is go
right next to each other it turns into
something way more provocative than
Intendant we'd like to have been there
when the teacher explained to the kid
why this space between Penn & is is so
important sea horses duh well this kid
sure is rambunctious
smart to say the least when asked if
you'd fill an aquarium with barnacles or
seahorses to interest your little
sibling in ocean life
the kid snaps back seahorses he goes on
to explain that you'd be an idiot to
fill an aquarium with boring barnacles
and then berated the teacher for giving
them such a dumb choice of ocean life to
choose between when the answer is so
obviously seahorses what would you
choose whatever you answer it letter B
seahorses or that kid will come after
you for sure dirty dirty feet Wow
okay things are heating up quick over
here in a religious school there are
often activities and texts to learn
about their beliefs
this student innocently drew a picture
of Jesus washing his disciples feet but
this drawing looks like it belongs
anywhere but religion class with Jesus
knelt in front of his disciple at crotch
level and the disciple with a smile on
his face saying you don't have to do
this
it looks more well dirty than clean
we'll let you figure out what's really
going on in that drawing but we
certainly hope Jesus didn't give his
disciples that much enjoyment I want to
be like mom when a class of students
were assigned a project to draw a
picture of what they wanted to be when
they grew up
this girl innocently drew her mother but
not exactly in the most sought after job
the kid drew what looked to be her
mother dancing on a pole with men
holding up dollar bills for her to take
the mother actually wrote the teacher
back explaining that she hasn't and
isn't an exotic dancer and that she
actually works at Home Depot last week
she told her daughter that it was so
busy at Home Depot and everyone wanted a
shovel that people were fighting over
the last one so the drawing is actually
her selling the last shovel not dancing
around a pole a first glance and without
explanation we're certain this teacher
was shocked smart aleck how
good did it feel when you outsmarted a
teacher there really is nothing like a
child outsmarting a teacher on a test
and this little kid did just that not
only did she not answer the question she
added in her own answer that made sense
to her sure she didn't do the math but
at least she's aware of health issues
hey are we right or are we right now
this one may not be innocent but it sure
is brilliant if we were the teacher we
would have given her a big check mark
snake has cookies wait until you hear
this one the whole way through the class
was asked to draw a picture and tell a
story about what they drew and this kid
got an a-plus in our books at least he
drew a fox in the woods but explained
how he was really a human he writes one
definition of the Fox is a clever sly
person so technically I'm right you're
wrong but it's okay because the snake
has cookies wait hold up a second the
snake has cookies where this kid should
win a nobel prize for best short story
cook right holy moly and we're off to
the misspelling races once again we'll
just give you a second here to read this
filled in answer by a young kid not
everyone is the a-plus speller that some
students are not every student can make
it to the spelling bee or even want to
make it there this answer was clearly
innocent and definitely misspelled this
kid filled in a reference to something
completely different instead of the word
cook we're gonna blame this one on the
creators of the English language for
making these words sound too similar
your mama
well this kid is getting sarcastic way
before they're a teenager when asked on
a test to fill in the answer to what
belongs to them but is used by their
friends more this little kid answered
your mama in the 21st century this
insult sure seems to be the retort from
every generation let's be honest we've
all replied your mom to a question we
don't know the answer to you from
friends on a test is a whole other level
of bravery so is this really an innocent
mistake by a student or a purposeful
response
we'll never know communism bonds it's
always a long day at school when we're
kids all we want to do is get the day
done with and go out and play well this
kid must have been mistaken which class
he was really in social studies or
science
he decided social studies when tested
about chemical bonds the teacher asked
to describe a situation in which people
become more stable when they share
something just like how some atoms share
electrons we know we don't get either
anyways the kidding answered communism
and his social studies teacher won the
prize sorry science teacher seems like
they missed something I can pee it's
really the small things that count and
it seems like this youngster Carson knew
that in space
yes Carson certainly can do a lot of
things and King is one of them in this
assignment the teacher one of the kids
to understand the use of I and this
little dude understood it perfectly when
asked what his favorite activity was
that he does by himself he answered I
can pee with just the letter P the
teacher wrote a note advising the
parents to talk about school behavior
teach you know he can actually Pete
write give the darn kid a bonus point
where is your humor threaten the teacher
it's always nice when the student and
teacher can have a bond this one
deserves a nod to the student for being
creative and a nod to the teacher for
having a great comeback the kid clearly
knew he wasn't going to be doing well on
this test so in the bonus question
he drew two stick figures with one
holding the other one at gunpoint the
student had the stick figures speak to
each other
threatening the teacher to award another
point even more clever was the teacher
who responded I don't negotiate with
terrorists California versus New Jersey
well this kid is Whittier than most
adults on a science test the teacher had
a question about the differences between
states of particles solid liquid and gas
when asked in which states do particles
move the quickest he answered California
obviously the teacher is meaning which
state as in solid liquid or gas not
literal American state the question
asked in which state particles move the
slowest the kid answered New Jersey
whether he heard this from home or not
this kid is a genius don't you think
lucky Olivia often in classes kids are
rewarded with stars or stickers for good
grades and good behavior in this
particular class olivia seemed to be the
chosen one this day olivia is a smart
little gal as it clearly says at the top
of the page that the lucky duck of the
day was her we guessed she either had
her name drawn or she had a good test an
innocent drug mistake that makes us all
giggle like children determination we're
gonna get a little darker on you here we
couldn't pass this one up because
obviously it was a misguided student
either by a teacher or an adult this kid
clearly didn't understand the weight of
the Holocaust when asked to draw a
picture based off a human value he chose
determination and used Adolf Hitler to
represent that he drew Hitler captioning
that he didn't stop at trying to take
over the world and had a lot of Germans
join his cause for his teaching history
may need to revise how they're
explaining the Second World War in
innocent mistake that only a child can
pull off Saturn is not a single lady
beyonce has successfully infiltrated
science class and it's about time if
this kids awesome answer doesn't get you
laughing and we don't know what will
when asked why are their rings on Saturn
this little tyke answered because God
liked it so we put a ring on it and the
thing that makes that even more
gut-wrenchingly hilarious is that the
teacher responded Saturn is not a single
lady it's just brilliant the melding of
pop culture religion and our solar
system is a beautiful thing
kids just never stop being kids pleaser
thank you which of these inappropriate
kid answers did you find the funniest
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching
[Music]